hi guys i'm karuchi tran
and i'm victor cruz and we are on this
week's episode of
[Applause]
sorry i'm getting confused i'm so
nervous i don't even know what i'm doing
i just know we're eating hot things so
please watch you guys
we're on this weekend i'm already
sweating and we haven't started yet so
there's that
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another episode of truth or dab
the hot one special where we give our
guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last dab
and today we have our first ever couples
edition of the program with victor cruz
and karuchi tran
he's the undrafted free agent turned pro
bowl wide receiver and super bowl
champion with the new york giants
she stars and tnt's claws and today
they'll stress test their relationship
over extremely spicy wings karuchi
victor
welcome to the show hey thanks for
having us man we appreciate it
in front of you you guys have three
wings and of course three hot sauces
various versions of the last dab
when i ask you a question you have a
choice answer it honestly
or eat a death wing and victor
will start with you of course and
there's some spicy talk
right to begin things thinking back on
your nfl career
can you specifically identify the most
trash cornerback you ever lined up
against
the most trash corner i've ever lined up
against
i can't tell the people
i can't do that to them because there's
somewhat of an honor code that we have
in the league
and i can't just do that because it
affects people's livelihoods
okay so i'm gonna have my first dab
this is i'm scared i'm nervous for you
[Music]
you gotta put a lot on there is that
enough for you
that's a solid though okay
i wasn't half back much better than
snitching
i'm all right we're just getting warmed
up here i'm
it good on you a little bit a little bit
the hot sauce has that way
of just sort of chasing you down oh
shoot okay that's my question
my right ear just got a little hot
victor while you chill out karuchi this
question's for you as someone who has an
obvious eye for personal style i'm
wondering if you can rank
these three victor cruz fashion collabs
from
best to worst and tell me why okay
his denim capsule collection with three
by one his vci sneakers with pierre
hardy the nike air trainer cruise
i'm a dab and i don't want to hurt your
feelings too so i respect that
okay get a good bite on that i get my
lip sweat
[Music]
how's it taste the chicken's phenomenal
by the way thank you guys for the
chicken goodness
i was easy peasy oh wow bring on the
heat whoa
whoa wow gauntlet dropped
moving on to the next round of
questioning here
all right victor let's start with you
again i see that karuchi has been
helping you out with your cooking skills
during quarantine but i'm curious
what's a dish that she makes that you
pretend to like to her face
but deep down you know needs some work
you just don't have the heart to tell
her
y'all can't do this to me man um
you know the good thing is we've spent a
lot of time together during these past
few months and i've gotten to
eat a lot of her dishes that she's made
and that she's concocted for us
in the home with that being said i'm
gonna open up the second round
i'm gonna open up the second round here
babe all your food is delicious
i'm gonna start be honest this is the
carolina reaper okay
there you go this is podesta oh [ __ ]
that's a lot
i should have shook it up
[Music]
i'm not afraid
cleaning wings he's hungry
oh my god awful
[Music]
that was not fun that one was not fun
am i blinking fast
on to you when we had joseph
gordon-levitt on the show recently he
told us the story of what he called his
auditioning rock bottom
looking back on your many years of doing
hollywood castings
is there an audition that you would
describe as the actual worst in your
memory
oh my gosh so
i auditioned for um
what is the show called with cookie
lions and um
oh um empire empire i auditioned for
empire for the role of tiana i think
that's her name
and this was in the beginning of my
career so i was still a little bit like
shy and you know
nervous and very much green and i had to
wrap nicki minaj
um which d's in the trap
i parade to i think about this randomly
all the time
but i pray that they burn those tapes
find the footage
if those two oh and the footage i just
might jump the bridge
no it was it was awful it was really
really bad can you give us a taste like
what was it no energy or was it just
it was just nerves and it was like bees
in the trap
yeah yeah yep yep yep so
wrapping is clearly not my thing
my nose is running so let's uh keep it
going here all right on to round number
three
all right so victor you were one of the
first major athletes signed by roc
nation an
agency founded by jay-z in 2013.
now that you're removed from the
politics of the front office
what would you say is the biggest thing
fans don't understand about the down and
dirty contract negotiation tactics that
are used by nfl teams
oh man i'd love to talk about this one i
knew it was real when my agent was going
after you know going and negotiating
with teams and he was like i don't know
i don't want you on these calls because
the way they talk about players and the
way they talk about the players as if
they're just pawns or moving pieces and
they make these comparisons of who you
are
and what type of player they believe you
to be
as opposed to what the numbers are what
the numbers state the numbers may state
one thing
but if they compare you to a certain
athlete that gets paid
10 million less than what you feel you
deserve or what your numbers indicate
that's what they're going to hold on to
and stick to so yes negotiations are
very very down and dirty in the nfl
no one seldomly asks the players how
they feel about
moving to a different team or how they
feel about their negotiations or how
their money's being handled
karuchi we're going to you on this one
you're
very much ahead of the curve when it
comes to celebrity makeup lines
launching kpop way before this sort of
uh celebrity cosmetic line gold rush
that we're experiencing now
can you give me one celebrity makeup
line that is actually worth the hype
and then another one that you think
maybe owes you royalties
but mind you she's in sephora at least
eight times a month
true i don't want any drama with anybody
from the beauty world because it gets a
little crazy
so i'm gonna try the carolina reaper
how's that one doing
my whole head is hot right now
the heat is definitely at the back end
i always like seeing that face when
someone bites in and then you just see
their eyes going from this way
to that way sizing it up doing circles
that's called we're contemplating life
in that very moment and what we want to
do
well the good news is we're approaching
the finish line here the last round
right here
victor this one's for you as we
mentioned up top karuchi plays virginia
lock in tnt's claws but what i want to
know right now is
do you even watch the show in season 2
when virginia shoots roller in defense
of desna
where do they hide the body under a desk
at the nail salon
inside of a surfboard bag or in the
trunk of desna's car
they put him in the trunk right
it wasn't true ate the wig
when i watched the show it was the
second episode of the first episode no
and then they know the shot roller we
put them in the surfboard bag
yeah put them in the circle lit the boat
on fire and whatever
no trunk this might have been before we
were dating
yeah season no we just started we just
started season two so i should have
definitely been watching it
shame what a shame i did watch though
you know i watched
but we gotta mix it up sorry guys
no kuruchi i can tell you're a person
who knows hot sauce
i do we were just talking about scotch
bonnet that's my favorite
yeah me too there's a scotch bonnet and
ginger sauce that's made by this company
queen majesty it's the best hot sauce in
the history of the world i have that at
home i bought i bought it at world
market but i haven't tried it is it good
it's awesome it's my favorite hot sauce
and i've i know hot sauce okay i'm gonna
try it when i get home
oh okay sure wasn't y'all put somebody
in the trunk at some point
i don't know what show you were watching
i don't know what girl
you were
triple x
this is not okay that looks
oh man
yeah i'm gonna be all right it's just a
matter of getting there
all right last question last question
and this one's for karuchi karuchi
looking back on your time as a celebrity
stylist
which one of your celebrity clients had
the worst personal style and needed your
help the most
ha come on
let me get my mouth ready for this
i'm sweating i'm just actual beat that
just came down
it's kicking in
it's getting hot
my mouth is like your face just got like
a shade right it's tingling a little bit
well there you have it another truth or
dab is in the books
karuchi pumping her fist victor cruz
dancing like you just scored a touchdown
close the curtains
roll the credits a pair of hot sauce
heroes it's like
moving to the front of my mouth now now
my lips growing
it's everything nasal passages
everything
we haven't had breakfast either by the
way so this is the first thing that
works
this is breakfast and we're both gonna
have like lava ass
[Music]
our ass is lava
[Applause]
[Music]
that was crazy why why do we agree to do
that i'm just glad it's over
wait wait first of all how did you not
know the answer to the clause question
well i obviously watch the show and i
love you
they put them in the trunk right how are
you not dying i'm sweating
profusely right now and you're just
chilling i got a little secret
i've been using your deodorant
oh it's by sweat defense
but that's mine ladies first yeah so now
i'm gonna use it because
men have skin too i'll leave you here to
be
okay enjoy
me sweat defense because men have skin
[Music]
too